Company data shows Apple's cash holdings nearly doubled...
...from 121 billion dollars to 232 billion.
But with 93 percent of that money held offshore,...
...Cook has taken heat from regulators and the US Senate,...
...accusing Apple of using subsidiaries in Ireland to reduce its tax bill.
Now, to product: Under Tim Cook, Apple's story is still all about the iconic iPhone.
In July, Apple sold its billionth unit...
...and the category accounts for nearly 57 percent of Apple's revenue.
But investors are waiting on another major product win...
...especially since the company has seen iPhone revenues decline...
...for the first time ever in the first two quarters of this year.
Some investors think Apple is overdependent on the iPhone...
...and worry about the impact of cooling demand in China.